[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur LCP pour cette émission
spéciale ce soir après ce coup de
théâtre dont on ne mesure pas encore
toutes les conséquences politiques seule
certitude c'est un très sérieux revers
pour le gouvernement qui a eu lieu cette
après-midi à l'Assemblée nationale
l'assemblée qui a refusé d'examiner le
projet de loi immigration les
oppositions du RN Alfi en passant par
les républicains le PS les écologistes
et les communistes se sont donc ligués
pour adopter ce qu'on appelle une motion
de rejet préalable alors beaucoup de
questions se posent ce soir d'abord
comment expliquer ce revers de la
majorité ce projet de loi est-il mort et
entérer quelle leçon Emmanuel Macron
va-t-il tirer de cette crise politique
majeure faut-il s'attendre à un
remanimement du gouvernement à un
changement de Premier ministre voire
éventuellement à une dissolution de
l'Assemblée nationale on en parle et en
débat et on en débat pendant une heure
avec nos invités et pour débattre donc
de cette situation politique j'accueille
en plateau ce soir Annie Genevard
bonsoir madame bonsoir vous êtes députés
les républicains du dou et c'est vous
qui étiez la responsable de ce texte au
sein de votre groupe LR Johann gilet
bonsoir député dur rassemblement
national du gare Arthur de la porte
bonsoir bonsoir député socialiste du
Calvados et porte-parole de votre groupe
à l'Assemblée Ludovic mendz vous
représentez la majorité vous êtes membre
du groupe Renaissance député de Mosel et
vous étiez l'un des rapporteur
thématique de ce projet de loi en charge
des titres 3 à 5 c'est bien ça bonsoir
enfin Olivier rouquan bonsoir merci
d'être à nos côté politologue enseignant
et chercheur en droit constitutionnel
notamment mais pour commencer cette
émission on va reconstituer un peu le
fil des événements avec Marco Pomier
Marco on va voir avec vous que c'est un
drame qui s'est déroulé en plusieurs
acte et qui s'est joué en grande partie
dans l'hémicycle oui Clément tout tient
en une phrase ou presque le le projet de
loi immigration du gouvernement balayé
par les députés avant même d'être
examiné dans l'hémicycle il était
17h42 très précisément lorsque yel Bron
pivé la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale annonce dans l'hémicycle les
résultats du scrutin voici le résultat
du scrutin votant 548 exprimé 535
majorité 268 pour 260 contre
265 l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté
en conséquence le projet de loi est
rejeté explosion de joie à des
oppositions camouflé pour le
gouvernement la gauche la droite et
l'extrême droite main dans la main pour
voter la motion de rejet préalable sur
le projet de loi immigration cette
motion été défendue par les écologistes
par un certain Benjamin Lucas en prenant
la parole vers 17h et bien le député
écologiste sait qu'il doit rallier à sa
cause les républicains et le
rassemblement national pour faire
adopter cette motion et il ne manque pas
d'arguments écoutter et c'est bien là le
seul objet de cette motion oui ou non le
gouvernement peut-il obtenir Infiné les
voix nécessaires à l'adoption de son
projet chacune et chacun ici connaît la
réponse ce vote doit permettre d'en
apporter la démonstration rejetons ce
mauvais texte
maintenant un débat aussi important que
celui-ci sans doute parmi les
controverses les plus importantes
politiquement et moralement de notre
époque mérite mieux qu'un petit texte
porté par une petite majorité il est
17h10 he lorsque Benjamin Lucas termine
sa prise de parole à la tribune de
l'Assemblée et déjà dans les médias
circule l'information que le
rassemblement national et les
républicain s'apprête à voter cette
motion de rejet alors Gérald haranin et
bien il sent le danger lorsque le
ministre de l'Intérieur prend la parole
dans l'hémicycle il tente le tout pour
le tout et il dénonce ce qu'il appelle
l'alliance de la carpe et du lapin
je n'ai pas peur du débat parce que vous
savez il y a des millions de Français
qui regardent les débats que nous
avons des millions et des millions qui
vont voir les députés du rassemblement
national et certains députés des
républicains vter avec Monsieur Lucas
qui veut la régularisation de tous les
sans
papier des arguments réfutés balayés par
le rassemblement national et par les
républicains écoutez-les depuis 18 mois
personne ne peut contester que les
députés les républicains aucun de vos
collègues ne peut contester que nous
sommes allés dans le sens de l'intérêt
général en votant les textes à chaque
fois qu'il nous paraissait nécessaire et
utile alors oui monsieur le ministre le
débat doit se poursuivre il doit se
poursuivre mais sur la base du texte de
fermeté proposé par le Sénat c'est le
sens de la motion de rejet que nous
soutiendrons car quand on a votre bilan
120 attaqu au couteau par jour un taux
d'exécution qui n'atteint même pas les 7
% des subventions aux associations
immigrationnistes qui frôent le milliard
d'euros entre 600000 et 900000
clandestins qui vivent sur notre sol et
plus de 400000 étrangers légaux qui
entrent en France chaque année on ne
vient pas donner des leçons en matière
de protection des Français la suite vous
la connaissez Clément le la motion de
rejet est adoptée l'examen du projet loi
migration à l'Assemblée nationale est
suspendu à 5 vois d'écart merci beaucoup
Marco pommier première question je la
pose à vous Ludovic mendz en tant que
représentant de de la majorité comment
est-ce que vous expliquez que toutes les
oppositions se soi ligué contre vous
aujourd'hui est-ce que la majorité
aurait dû s'y prendre différemment sur
ce texte alors je crois que c'est à eux
qu'il faut demander parce que nous on a
essayé de travailler avec toutes les
bonnes person les personnes une volonté
non
mais on peut le voir comme un échec on
peut le voir autrement chacun le le le
verra de sa façon on nous a expliqué que
la première ministre ne respectait pas
le le Parlement et qu'elle mettait des
493 à tout vaa sur des sujets où sur
lesquels on savait qu'on tomberait
jamais d'accord l'arrêté c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ce sont les
parlementaires eux-mêmes qui se sont
bayonnés ils se sont interdits de
pouvoir débattre c'est assez étonnant
d'entendre autant de personnes sur tous
les plateaux télé nous expliquer qu'il
faut parler d'immigration et le moment
où on leur donne la possibilité de le
faire ben ils s'interdisent de pouvoir
en débattre ce qui est assez étonnant
aussi c'est de voir que des personnes
comme Benjamin Luca ont passé leurs
semaines à insulter en commission des
lois les députés LR de racistes de
droite radicalisé qu' que les LR puisse
voter avec eux moi j'ai la sensation à
titre personnel que au moment où Eric
sooti appuie sur le même bouton que les
puté appartenant au groupe de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il signe l'arrêt de mort en
fait DLR c'est ça l'arrêté de on sait
pas où on va l'arrêté c'est qu'auj'hui à
coup du côté de la majorité sur la façon
don la recherche vois pas où on peut le
reprocher des erreurs en commission des
lois nous avons pris des amendements de
presque tous les groupes politiques
pourquoi déposer autant d'amendements
dans ce cas si on veut pas travailler
oui je vous vois secouer la tête
monsieur gilet on n pas pris ce dun et
de la France insoumise mais on a
travaillé avec les socialistes avec les
écologistes avec l on a essayé de
travailler aussi avec lesr l'arrêter est
là c'està dire qu'on a toujours tendu la
main on a toujours voulu construire à
plusieurs sur l'intégration on savait
qu'une partie des LR ne serait pas
d'accord sur la partie fermeton avec une
partie de la gauche ne serait pas
d'accord mais ça nousceil fallait pas
cinder ce texte en deux comme ça a été
envisagé à un moment mettre la partie
répression dans un texte de loi et la
partie intégration dans dans un autre
mais pourquoi pour vous dire on aager
des majorit quand on parle d'immigration
ce qu'on nous demande aujourd'hui c'est
une meilleure intégration et plus de
fermeté avec des personnes qui ne
méritent pas d'être sur not seul
l'arrêté c'est que on peut tout mettre
dans le même texte il faut que chaque
groupe politique prenne ses
responsabilités certains sont dans le
dogme politique de base en disant on
veut combattre Emmanuel Macron donc par
principe on va s'opposer à tout d'autres
nous expliquent on doit faire plus mais
s'ils veulent faire plus débattons on
nous a empêché de débattre à partir de
là on a on a une part de responsabilité
je suis pas le genre de député de la
majorité à expliquer que on est
responsable de rien on a une part de
responsabilité on est en majorité on est
relatif certes on est en responsabilité
avec le gouvernement donc c'est à nous
de de tendre la main mais on peut pas
dire que Gérald haranin n'a pas tendu la
main d'ailleurs on nous a expliqué qu'au
Sénat ça n'atterrirait jamais ça a
atterri avec des cavaliers législatifs
et avec la rité c'est qu'un conseil
constitionnel nous aurait censuré sur
beaucoup de ces sujet les LR le savaiit
et malgré tout ils ont préféré continuer
sur cette ligne-là alors il y a une
réalité que plusieurs sondages en tout
cas a établi c'est que ce projet de loi
été plédicité par une très large
majorité de Français euh alors vous
trois qui représentez les une partie des
oppositions euh vous allez devoir
justifier le vote de cette motion de
rejet auprès de vos électeurs on va
regarder le ce sondage xa qui avait été
réalisé pour le Figaro le 1er novembre
dernier sur la base du projet de loi
initial du gouvernement il était
approuvé par 78 % des Français parmi en
tout cas les Français qui disaient
connaître ce texte c'està-dire qu'il
s'était penché sur le sujet en détail on
va voir plus en détail que si on regarde
en fonction de l'appartenance politique
73 % des sympathisants du parti
socialiste approuvé ce texte 75 % des
sympathisants des républicains 77 % des
sympathisants du rassemblement national
Johann gilet euh je me tourne vers vous
pour le rassemblement national comment
comptez-vous expliquer à vos électeurs
que vous ayez refusé de débattre de ce
texte qui était donc approuvé par 77 %
de vos électeurs mais c'est très simple
euh d'ailleurs on le voit depuis le le
rejet de ce texte en hémicycle euh
nombreux sont les électeurs au contraire
à nous remercier parce que ce sont bien
les voix du rassemblement national qui
ont fait pencher et qui ont permis de
rejeter ce texte nocif pour le pays donc
il vous remercie de ne pas débattre d'
mainant je vais vous expliquer en votant
ce texte nous avons protégé les Français
protéger les Français de l'objectif de
ce texte qui était de renforcer la
submersion migratoire voilà quel était
l'objectif de ce texte et je peux vous
dire que ce sondage là où il est tronqué
c'est qu'en réalité comment la question
avait été posée aux Français voulez-vous
du texte présenté par géralde Darmanin
visant à mieux encadrer l'immigration et
à réguler et empêcher l'immigration
clandestine les Français ont l
légitimement répondu oui mais la réalité
du texte était tout autre et donc en
cela les Français comprennent tout à
fait j'en suis convaincu notre choix de
rejeter ce texte très nocif pour le pays
Annie genunevard je vous pose la la même
question pour vous pour les républicains
euh est-ce que vous n'avez pas fait un
peu de politique politicienne
aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée au risque de
vous fâcher avec vos propres électeurs
non je crois que c'est vraiment un choix
que nous avons pesé dont nous avons
évalué toutes les conséquences mais
qu'est-ce qui nous était proposé
d'accepter ou de rejeter le texte issu
de la commission des lois ce texte
modifiait ou renonçait à 66 % des
dispositions prises par le Sénat donc
nous en signifiant le rejet du texte
issu de la commission nous avons dit
nous voulons revenir au texte du Sénat
c'est le sens de notre vote mais vous
pensez que vos électeurs vont comprendre
ça mais je crois que si on explique aux
électeurs que en commission des loi de
l'Assemblée nationale la majorité a
renoncé au délit de séjour irrégulier a
renoncé à la déchéance de nationalité à
renoncer à la fin du droit du sol
automatique à renoncer à modifier à
réformer l'ame à renoncer à la caution
étudiante à renoncer on faire une liste
interminable mais av qu chos dans av
encore de il y avait encore deux il y
avait encore deux dispositions que la
commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale a rejeté c'est la
conditionnalité
des prestations sociales non
contributives à moins qu'on ne réside
depuis plus de 5 ans et enfin le fichier
des mineurs délinquants qui sont un
énorme problème pour les départements
donc ce que nous avons dit c'est que ce
texte issu de la commission il n'est pas
acceptable parce que il il renonce à des
mesures de fermeté qui sont
indispensables aujourd'hui
indispensables pour mettre fin
effectivement à une immigration qui
n'est plus contrôlée et la meilleure
preuve preuve la meilleure preuve c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le Conseil d'État a
déclaré obligé le gouvernement à
rapatrier asses frais un oubec qui avait
été expulsé de France au motif que il
pourrait
encourir des mesures préjudiciables à sa
vie ou à sa dignité dans son pays donc
vous voyez bien que le le le les les
redemontades de la Major bien compris
vous aviez des Gries contre ce texte ne
sont pas ne ne ne ne peuvent pas
satisfaire les Français qui ont
légitimement et avec bon sens qui disent
on ne peut plus intégrer parce que ça
n'est plus sous contrôle Arthur de la
porte la parole est à vous juste je vous
pose cette même question quand vous
voyez que près de trois électeurs du
Parti socialiste sur 4 était favorable à
ce texte est-ce que vous êtes pas
déconnecté de votre électorat
aujourd'hui sur cette question de
l'immigration je vais vous dire à quand
j'ai organisé dans ma circonscription
une réunion sur le texte on a pris le
temps avec un avocat de décrypt les
grandes mesures il y avait plus de 300
personnes c'est l'une des réunions qui a
attiré le plus de monde dans toutes cell
que j'ai organisé et je peux vous dire
que à la fin il y avait plus une
personne qui soutenait le texte quand
ils avaient vu ce que ce texte contenait
réellementais sa pas encore
précis parce que on a dit voilà l'aide
médicale de l'état avait été introduite
enfin la suppression de l'aide médicale
d'État avait été introduite par le Sénat
on est revenu dessus et heureusement en
commission des Affaires soci alors la
modification de l'aide médicale d'État
proposée par les républicains était
approuvée par une majorité d'électeurs
socialistes justement et et justement
mais dès qu'on explique ce que c'est que
l'aide médicale d'État son cous réel
l'incidence sur même la santé des
Français le fait que ça fasse même des
économies à la sécurité sociale que ça
évite d'engorger l'hôpital et bien là
bizarrement les gens ne font plus ah
l'aide médical d'État quel scandale
quand on a les républicains et le RN qui
nous rabachent à longueur de journée que
l'aide médicale d'État sert à faire de
la chirurgie d'oreille ça c'est ce que
vous nous avez rabacher et bien on
regarde dans le détail c'est moins de
50000 € ça représente par an à l'échelle
du pays 50000 € et vous nous faites fait
des débats des heures de débat là-dessus
donc voyez nous pourquoi on a rejeté ce
texte parce que on a voulu mettre fin à
ce débat malsin à ce débat falsifié à ce
débat finalement qui reposait sur des
mauvaises bases avec un ministre de
l'Intérieur qui avait dit on sera gentil
avec les gentils méchant avec les
méchants bref un débat extrêmement
maniquéin qui montre aussi par ailleurs
l'échec du en même temps parce qu'on ne
peut pas être en même temps gentil avec
les gentils d'ailleurs ce texte ne
l''était pas et méchant avec les
méchants ce discours est une imposture
il y avait une imposture de la part du
gouvernement et un échec de la part de
jardin assum j'aimerais vous entendre
vous votre analyse sur ce qui s'est
passé cet après-midi à l'Assemblée et
sur ce qu'on constate cet écart entre ce
vote aujourd'hui d'une majorité pour
refuser de débattre de ce projet de loi
et les les sondages qui donnaient une
opinion majoritairement favorable au
texte les sondage qui vient d'être
évoqué est intéressant puisqu'on voit un
décalage alors c'est un petit
inchantillon mais non négligeable à
l'échelle d'une circonscription de 300
personnes et ça montre quand même
aujourd'hui la difficulté de la
procédure législative par rapport à son
appropriation sur surtout sur des sujets
très clivés très polémiques donc il faut
un temps d'appropriation part le débat
n'était pas le temps d'appropriation par
les citoyens grâce à la chaîne
parlementaire
qui qu'on évoque quand même ce projet un
an et demi qu'on évoque ce projet que ce
qui se dessine et donc il y a peut-être
une difficulté finalement à communiquer
un certain nombre de sur des sujets
aussi complexes et une difficulté qui
consiste à la fois à simplifier à
polariser l'opinion donc après les
sondages suivent puis la réalité des
choses et puis sur ce qui s'est passé
cet après-midi bon ben la question elle
est posée depuis le début de ce
quinquena c'est-à-dire que la majorité
si vous voulez lorsqu'elle se heurte à
la conjonction des oppositions elle est
elle est elle est minoritaire quelque
part et donc c'est la difficulté à
consolider finalement un centre
politique suffisamment solide pour
continuer à voter des textes ceci dit il
ne faut pas non plus on est on est sorti
si vous voulez de la 5e République
bipolarisée depuis 2017 avec des
majorités franches et l'assurance que
les textes soient votés sans trop de
problème alors ce centre là on voit bien
qu'il y a peut-être sur des sujets comme
l'immigration euh une je sais pas si
c'est une volonté mais une conjonction
de circonstances qui fait qu'on
reviendrait peut-être à une
bipolarisation alors différente de celle
qu'on a connu mais c'est toute la toute
la question est-ce que les chocs qui se
présentent l'immigration le climat ou
autres vont permettre de conserver ce
modèle d'une majorité un centre polarisé
avec deux ailes qui sent pourrai
s'entendre une conjonction des
contraires mais le problème c'est que
derrière il n'y a pas la construction
possible pour l'instant d'une majorité
de rechange alors on a vu avec Marco
Pomier comment les choses se sont
déroulées dans l'hémicycl mais une
grande partie s'est joué aussi dans les
coulisses et on va en parler avec vous
elsondin Gava car vous avez suivi tout
cela pour nous tout au long de
l'après-midi Elsa oui exactement depuis
cette St des qure colonne ce que je peux
vous dire c'est quand à 16h la séance
commence il y a des choses qu'on sait on
sait qu'il y aura une motion de rejet on
sait que la nupè vatera pour on sait que
la majorité votera compte mais il y a
deux inconnus le positionnement du
rassemblement national et celui des
républicains le rassemblement national
il a tenu une réunion de groupe à 15h30
vers 15h50 on voit tout sourire les
députés les trouples de Marine Le Pen
passer dans cette salle des quatre
colonnes mais ils ne disent aucun mot
sur le choix qu'ils effectuent ensuite
donc Gérald armanin prend la parole dans
l'hémicycle et puis c'est autour des
républicains de mener une réunion de
groupe un peu plus tard dans un bureau
près de l'Assemblée là on nous dit
qu'Olivier marlex et ERC sooti essayent
de convaincre le plus grand nombre de
leur troupes de voter en faveur de cette
motion de RET rejet on sent évidemment
dans la majorité beaucoup d'inquiétude
puisque c'est eux qui apprennent que le
RN va voter pour cette motion et que
beaucoup de LR pourrai s'associer à ces
voix ça va être très très très très
serré nous nous indictons dans
l'hémicycle côté gouvernement on reste à
peu près confiant jusqu'à la prise de
parole de Gérald armanin qui semble dans
un dernier moment avant le vote et bien
jouer un peu le tout pour le tout pour
convaincre certains de ne pas voter et
puis le résultat tombe la motion de
rejet est adopté ce qu'on sait c'est que
le RN a fait un choix un choix politique
il considérait qu'il était gagnant dans
les deux cas mais qu'il avait plus de
point à gagner à mettre le gouvernement
à terre à affaiblir Gérald haranin
plutôt qu'à avoir de SEM de débat dans
l'hémicycle on va revenir dans un
instant vers vous Elsa mais Johann
Gillet vous confirmez cette analyse de
bah du choix qui a été fait par le le
rassemblement national c'était gagnant
gagnant dans tous les cas pour vous non
notre décision elle a été prise dans le
sens de l'intérêt général en
l'occurrence lors de notre réunion il a
fallu se positionner pour savoir quel
était le meilleur choix pour la France
et en l'occurrence comme nous
considérons que ce texte ne va pas dans
le bon sens qu'il est nocif pour le pays
nous avons décidé de ne pas prendre le
risque et bien VI de le faire
adopterement la l'objectif était de
faireage à ce texte et certainement pas
de ne pas avoir de débat parce qu'on ne
peut pas reprocher au rassemblement
national de ne pas vouloir débattre
d'immigration alors que nous remettons
le sujet sur la table régulièrement et
que nous proposons d'ailleurs d'ors et
déjà au gouvernement d'entamer un
nouveau débat et que dès demain Marine
Le Pen proposera d'ailleurs et déposera
à l'Assemblée nationale une proposition
de loi pour faciliter l'expulsion des
délinquants étrangers alors on va
retourner du côté de la salle des qure
colonnes mais cette fois avec cl
pour avoir la réaction des écologistes
vous êtes Clément avec Julien Baillou
bonsoir Julien Baillou donc la motion de
rejet porté par votre groupe a été
adopté grâce au voix notamment du
rassemblement national pour des raisons
très différentes des
vôtres quelle a été la la recette
finalement pour arriver à faire voter ce
texte est-ce que cette alliance un peu
baroque fait sens non mais la question
c'est que le texte est mauvais et donc
il y a une majorité contre tout
simplement il y a pas d'alliance il y a
pas de machin vous Prz le principe
motion de rejet et vote cette motion qui
veut ceux qui sont contre ce texte il se
trouve qu'il y a une majorité contre ce
texte et donc le le gouvernement doit en
tirer les leçons c'est pas une victoire
des écologistes ce soir nous avons
proposé de rejeter ce texte il y a une
majorité de députés qui ont dit oui
rejetons ce texte qu'est-ce qu'on doit
en tirer comme leçon que le gouvernement
a perdu un vote et qu' doit retirer ce
texte c'est pas la fin du monde c'est
pas un un tremblement de terre ça arrive
en démocratie on perd des votes et bien
aujourd'hui le gouvernement a perdu un
vote il doit retirer ce texte et moi
j'aimerais qu'on puisse enfin se
concentrer sur des sujets que les
Français attendent les salaires le
logement le rétablissement des services
publics et la lutte contre le vous
pensez que les Français n'attendaient
pas un texte sur l'immigration non moi
écoutez en tout cas pour ce que les gens
m'interpellent on me parle de logement
on me parle de service publics on me
parle de lutte enfin contre le
dérèglement climatique on me parle
d'équipement des pompiers on me parle de
ces prix toujours plus haut pour se
chauffer pour se nourrir mais quand on
me parle d'immigration c'était pour me
dire il faut les
régulariser voilà régularison ces
personnes qui sont dans la précarité ça
on peut le faire et il y aura les
écologies pour le voter pour tout ce qui
est des textes toujours plus difficile
toujours plus précarisant il y en a pas
besoin pourtant les sondages opinions
que nous avons montré en début
d'émission semblaient indiquer l'inverse
ce texte semblait plébisité par les
Français oui bah si vous demandez aux
Français si on est pour l'augmentation
des salaires il y a bien sûr une
majorité le gouvernement l'a pas fait si
vous demandez aux Français s'il y a une
majorité pour une équité fiscale pour
rétablir les services publics bon ben
voilà donc les sondages voyez c'est un
peu facile l'enjeu c'est pas un 30e
texte ou un 20e texte en 30 ans sur
l'immigration l'enjeu c'est la
régularisation il y a 600000 à 700000
personnes qui sont absolument cruciales
pour l'économie qui sont dans une
situation de précarité incroyable et qui
malgré elle jouent un rôle de dumping
social quand on a régularisé massivement
en 1981 ça a augmenté les salaires de
l'ensemble des Français voilà ce qu'on
pourrait faire voilà du concret très
bien merci à vous merci à vous et merci
à vous Clément Perro alors on l'a dit
hein le vote de cet après-midi sur cette
motion de rejet préalable c'est joué à
quelques voix près il est donc
intéressant de se pencher en détail sur
le vote qui a voté quoi quelle voix ont
fait défaut au Gouvernement sur ce sur
ce vote et Elsa bah Vous vous êtes
penché sur le sur le vote quelle leçon
en avez-vous tiré alors je vous rappelle
270 voix pour 265 voix contre contre
alors quand on analyse dans le détail la
quasi totalité des députés de la
majorité étai présent et ils ont voté
contre la motion de rejet il y a
toutefois une petite dizaine de députés
entre Renaissance horizon et le modemme
qui n'étit pas présents alors on nous
explique qu'ils auraient pu par exemple
avoir des problèmes de santé mais pas ne
pas avoir pu faire leur délégation dans
les temps sur une motion de rejet on
peut faire une délégation de vote mais
pour des cas très précis erreur
technique mais comme on le sait le
scrutin s'est joué à quelques voix près
donc ça compte les députés de laanupes
étaient aussi très trésmobilisé
aujourd'hui ainsi que ceux du
rassemblement national 87 voix sur 88 et
puis quand on se pche sur le groupe les
républicains un groupe aussi très
mobilisé puisque il y a eu 40 voix pour
c'était vraiment une fourchette très
très haute je pense que le gouvernement
ne s'imaginait pas que 40 députés LR
allaient pouvoir voter pour la motion de
rejet deux députés ont voté contre et 11
se sont abstenus voici donc les
enseignements de ce scrutin des LR très
mobilisés et un rassemblement national
en rôle d'arbitre merci beaucoup Elsa
mondingava Annie Genevard quand même un
commentaire sur le détail de de ce
scrutin oui j'ai regardé les chiffres
bon la majorité le groupe Renaissance
compte
170 députés euh et il n'a pas fait le
plein de ses voix et s'il y avait eu 170
députés Renaissance qui avaient voté
contre cette motion de rejet le texte ne
serait pas passé on était on était à
égalité parfaite 270 270 et dans ce
cas-là la motion de rejet aurait été
rejetée donc je pense que le
gouvernement doit aussi regarder ce qui
se passe chez lui et la majorité
manifestement n'a pas fait le plein
c'est donc que ce texte é clivant à tous
égards et dans tous les groupes en même
temps juste avant que vous ne réagissiez
Ludovic mandes il y a aussi une ligne de
fracture dans votre groupe même si elle
est moins importante que ce qu'on
pouvait penser mais 11 abstentions et
deux votes contre ça montre bien que
votre groupe lui aussi est divisé sur ce
sujet alors nous avion que tout le monde
n'était pas sur la même longueur d'onde
par rapport à cette motion de rejet en
revanche ce qui faisait l'unanimité chez
nous c'est la base du texte du Sénat
nous voulions revenir à la discussion du
texte du Sénat parce que si nous
n'avions pas rejeté le texte issu de la
Commission et bien c'est le texte de la
commission qui s'imposait et on était
privé d'un certain nombre de sujets de
discussion par la règle dite de
l'antonois
par exemple tous les amendements
relatifs à l'aide médicale d'État étai
déclarés irrecevable c'est un sujet que
nous n'aurions pas pu évoquer donc nous
nous voulions discuter de l'intégralité
du sujet sur l'immigration parce que
c'est ça que les Français attendent
Ludovique mendz vous voulez répondre à
nenvar qui a un peu mis en cause la
mobilisation au sein de de votre groupe
R naaissance on est présent 97 % donc
oui ça peut arriver qu'il y ait des
quque on a deux collègues qui
malheureusement on en voyé trop tard
leur demande de délégation de vote pour
raison de maladie on a deux autres
personnes qui sont des
députés et 1 2 3 qui ont été élus pour
représenter des des Français à
l'étranger majoritairement en Asie et au
Moyen-Orient donc il y a eu un quak
aussi et on essaie de comprendre ce qui
s'est passé globalement était là mais je
crois que c'est juste une manière de
Madame jeevard d'expliquer qu'en fait le
problème il est pas chez eux alors que
la ré du problème il est chez eux ils
étaient pas à plein non plus euh je
crois que la réunion s'est pas très bien
passé de leur côté et que depuis un
certain temps et d'ailleurs en
commission vous arrêtez pas de nous
parler de la commission mais l'arrêz
c'est qu'en commission vous n'étiez pas
présent vous étiez- vous présente Madame
jeevard on a eu msour camardine aussi
vous étiez la seule d'ailleurs à voter
avec msour camardine le le vendredi soir
parce que vos collègues n'étaient pas
présents et arrêé c'est que vous nêtes
pas battu en fait en commission pour
essayer de maintenir un texte soitdisant
vous éti tout seul donc le groupe les
républains ne s'est pas B alors vous
avezêtre pas
été h h membres de la commission des
lois nous sommes h membres de la
commission des lois con était tous les
quat en commission des lois et on peut
dire le parti politique le le moins bien
représenté pendant plus d'une
semain mais on pe en parler on est
les donc il arêé entre les h présents et
ceux qui avent le droit de vote il y
aussi il y a aussi un écart et il y a
des collègues qui sont ven défendre des
AM V vousz d vous battre en commission
des lois vous ne l'avez pas
fait mainant sur ce qui s'est passé il
faut accepter aussi de perdre je veux
dire il faut avoir une forme d'humilité
il faut accepter de se dire que on peut
pas gagner à tous les coups c'est une
réalité on aurait pu dégainer un 493
avant cette motion et non ah non juste
avant non que la DG n pas commencé vous
avez raison c'était pas l'idée non plus
et il y a même pas eu la possibilit il y
a pas eu d'éco même dans la dans dans
dans le weekend d'unible 493 ce lundi
donc ça a démontré que notre objectif
Ctait de débattre et on nous avait
assurer plus ou moins qui voulait
débattre vous nous parlez de la me en
permanence il y a un rapport qui a ééé
l'aide médicale d'État qui a été comme
vous le savz qui est un cavalier
législatif donc c'està dire que vous
auriez préféré mentir au français en
disant que le Parlement avait voté des
dispositions qui n'auraient jamais été
appliqué parce qu'ils ont été ils
auraient été retoqués par le consé
cavalier législatif c'està-dire que aux
yeux du droit constitutionnel ça ne
pouvait pas être dans ce texte de loi la
rité c'est vous auriez dit au français
on a voté quelque chose mais c'est pas
notre faute c'est c'est c'est la
Constitution donc ça vous permettait de
rappeler que vous vouliez changer la
constitution donc en fait quoi qu'il
arrive vous étiez rentré dans dans
quelque chose que vous pouviez pas
sortir mais en faisant ça vous avez
donné les clés à Marine Le Pen mais vous
vlez toujours pas l'accep par qu'en fait
vous dites exactement la même chose que
Marine Le Pen et en commission des lois
les députés du RN ont remis plus ou
moins les LR à leur place et des fois
par leur gauche et des fois par leur
droite je rappelle qu'and quand même une
députée RN qui a dit à Eric soti que il
manquait d'humanité c'est quand même
assez exceptionnel quand on voit
certains propos tenus sur les plateaux
télé donc ça démontre à quel point la
famille politique ne sait plus où elle
va et puis vous n'z pas confiance vous
n'aviez pas confiance dans vos sénateurs
pour une commission mixte parire pour
pouir peut-être modifier des choses et
se Batt pour
garder des questions jus répondre après
on va écouter d'autres réaction Politi
si vousoulez
bien je vais vous répondre Monsieur
M en commission sur l'examen du texte de
la proposition de loi
constitutionnelle avez voté ave laanupes
contre l'article 7 qui permet
l'expulsion des des délinquants
étrangers vous avez voté avec laanupes
contre cette
DISP c'est pas ça mais vous voyez bien
en fait moi j'assiste à cet échange en
spectateur un peu désabusé et en me
disant mais voilà voilà l'image que je
ne voulais pas que nous renvoyions au
français un espèce d'accusation
permanente en oubliant le fond du sujet
le fond du sujet c'est quoi c'est qu'on
avait un texte qui était profondément
injuste un texte qui allait faire en
sorte de mettre en scène pendant 3
semaines un débat pitoyable un débat
lamentable un débat qui repose sur des
fake news alimentés par le rassemblement
national reprise par LR et dans laquelle
dans lesqueles Gérald d'Anin
s'engouffrait il suffit de voir ce qui
s'est passé ce weekend quand le ministre
de l'Intérieur envoie à tous les députés
des communiqués pour dire coco Rico
regardez ce qu'on va faire avec montex
et que ses communiqués sont truffé de
faute sont truffi d'espèces de de gros
mensonges permanent écoutez moi c'est
pas ça que j'aiattends du débat public
j'aiattends du débat public un peu de
sérénité et un peu de dignité et qu'on
pense derrière aux gens qui sont
derrière tout ça parce que on a eu des
débats par exemple en commission sur la
question des TF obligation de quitter le
territoire français qui sont exécutés à
un taux très bas en France et on dit
exécuter un taux très bas ce taux a
baissé prenons cet exemple c'est 6 %
d'exécution ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'on prononce des octf à tour de
bras en gros on en a on a doublé le
nombre de volonté d'expulsion en
l'espace de 5 ans depuis que Emmanuel
Macron est arrivé au pouvoir mais on a
pas réussi à renvoyer deux fois plus
vite les gens on est resté sur un taux à
peu près stable de renvoi des gens mais
pourquoi parce que ces cttf qui sont
derrière ces ocutf des familles des gens
des gens qui travaillent moi dans ma
circonscription ça peut être je sais pas
des carleurs qui sont bénévoles dans des
association qu' des enfants des familles
et derrière en fait pr pron des f à tour
de bras mais ça ce débat là ce débat il
est impossible parce que on va donner
l'impression que l'étranger il est
criminalisé que c'est un délinquant en
permanence alors en fait c'est
simplement des gens qui veulent vivre
dans notre pays et en fait moi j'avais
pas envie de ce débat ce débat je le
trouve indigne indigne de nos valeurs
mais aussi indigne de la réalité parce
que on est dans une situation de
déconnexion totale avec d'un côté des
gens qui ont juste envie de travailler
de s'intégrer en France et de l'autre
des responsables politiques de droite
d'extrême droite et de la majorité qui
instrumentalise le débat parce qu'il le
croi populaire parce qu'il le croit
finalement nécessaire alors que derrière
vous n'z rien changer dans la réalité
c'est d'ailleurs ce que vous reprochez
l' vous n'alliez pas faire que vos
excutf aurait été mieux exécuté vous
n'alliez pas améliorer la condition des
migrants qui se gèlent dans les rues
aujourd'hui en France parce qu'il y a
plus assez de place dans l'hébergement
d'urgence vous n'aliez pas améliorer la
situation des demandeurs d'asile que les
républicains ou le rassemblement
national veulent dégrader et c'est bien
ça le problème c'est que ce texte il ne
répondait à aucune Gil et après on va
écouter d'autres réactions politiques
qui ont eu lieu cette après-midi sur le
sujet des TF parce que c'est très
intéressant le sujet des TF est
révélateur sur ce texte à à plusieurs
points quand on voit la position de la
gauche la gauche finalement ne veut pas
d'qtf parce que la gauche veut toujours
plus d'immigration et ne veut pas col
renvoyer les personnes qui sont
présentes illégalement sur le territoire
français par contre ces otf elles
étaient aussi l'un des axes du mensonge
de de géraldde daranin parce qu'il faut
le dire Gérald d'Anin nous a dit depuis
plusieurs jours depuis plusieurs
semaines même que ce texte allait
permettre de renforcer les EF et de
permettre de mieux expulser les
délinquants étrangers c'était un
mensonge effectivement pourquoi parceen
fait ce ce texte permettait de délivrer
davantage deqtf ça c'est vrai délivré
davantage deqtf sauf que ça ne veut pas
dire que ces TF auraient été réalisés
parce qu'on le sait l'un des problèmes
majeurs de la non exécution de ces OQTF
c'est le fait que la France n'est pas
respectée à l'international et le fait
que les pays d'origine des personnes à
expulser refusent de nous délivrer les
laisser passer consulaires et nous nous
proposions par vot d'amendement qui a
été refusé par la gauche par la macronie
et par l'lr il faut le préciser et bien
de sanctionner les pays d'origine de
manière financière en coupant les aides
au dévelopement
monsieur mend vous étiez en charge
justement je crois de l'éloignement des
étrangers dans la partie du projet de
loi qui n'a pas été débattu de nous
délivrer les laisser passer consulaire
qui assez lunaire excusez-moi de ce
terme mais c'est que le r nous explique
onexulsera pas plus ce qui est faut
l'arêté c'était il y a des verroues
législatifes qu'on avait besoin de de
retirer et qui était proposé dans cette
loi il nous parle de mettre la pression
financière c'est dans la loi il y a la
possibilité de de donner au gouvernement
de limiter ce qu'on a l'aide publique au
développement aux pays qu'on accompagne
qui sont souvent des pays pour lesquels
nous avons des sortisant sur territoire
national qu'on accueille ou que nous
refusons d'accueillir pareil sur les
visas dans la loi il était prévu qu'on
puisse mettre la pression à certains
pays en disant on vous remet plus de
visa pour que vos ressortissants
viennent sur notre territoire national
en contrepartie de laisser passer
consulaire donc tout ça c'était dans la
loi c'est déjà possible aujourd'hui vous
ne le faites pas c'est pas vrai c'est
pas c'est pas aussi que ça et vous le
savez le seul pays avec lequel ça été
mis en place c'est avec la Gambie et il
y a eu une grosse pression sur les pays
du Maghreb et ça a plutôt bien
fonctionné mais au malheureusement ça a
aussi dégradé nos relations
diplomatiques et c'est ce qu'on doit
aussi renforcer on avait mis plusieurs
moyens et si on ne lutte pas contre les
passeurs les filières de proximitisme de
travail indigne de logement indigne ou
insalubre comme on le proposait dans la
loi et c'est c'était une partie de de de
des articles que j'avais sous ma
responsabilité on ne luttera pas contre
les personnes qui viennent sur le
territoire national on si on ne lutte
pas contre les passeurs et qu'on ne
limite pas la traite humaine et qu'on ne
fait pas en sorte de pouvoir mieux
lutter contre la traite humaine on aura
toujours des personnes qui arriveront
dans des situations irrégulières dans
notre en situation irrégulière dans
notre pays et qui pour beaucoup n'ont
pas volonté de venir dans notre pays
aussi j'ai rencontré aussi ce type de
personnes à plusieurs reprises qu'on
peut croiser malheureusement à hustream
à caléis à Paris partout parce que ce
sont des ressortissants étrangers qui
ont jamais voulu venir ici et une fois
qu'ils étaient sur le territoire
européen sont dit dans quel pays je peux
aller pour me sentir mieux et la
majorité d'entre eux ne veulent pas
venir en France le problème que nous
avons et le dernier problème que nous
avons c'est qu'on mélange tous les chifê
quelque part un peu sur un point celui
de du débat parlementaire un peu
paradoxal euh si on se rappelle du débat
sur les retraites ou ou par ailleurs sur
le budget ce qui est reproché souvent
c'est l'usage
d'outils dont l'exécutive dispose pour
faire taire les parlementaires et ça
avait été particulièrement été critiqué
et mis en avant lors du débat sur les
retraites avec l'article 38 au Sénat le
443 le 493 et là il est vrai quand même
que ce sont les parlementaires eux-mêmes
qui avec cette motion de rejet s ont
décidé de ne pas débattre et c'est év
l'argument qui a employé par Gérald
Darmanin dans l'ém qui soit employé par
Gérald daranin le gouvernement ou
d'autres ce sont des faits h ce sont des
faits ce qu'il y a c'est donc c'est pas
pour arranger Géral larmanin mais c'est
par rapport à l'opinion publique je me
demande quel écho cette motion de rejet
aura dans la perception du
fonctionnement de notre débat est-ce que
vous expliquer tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire euh il vaut mieux qu' pas
ce débat finalement parce que il est
extrmeoite fake new vous disiez ministre
surj
mais le débat parlementaire peut
permettre avec sa force quand même de de
remettre en cause cette en commission
moi j'ai pas eu
l'impression espèce de dialogue entre
passe-moi je te passe le poivre entre la
majorité et les républicains allez on va
on va juste on va juste s'arrêter
quelques instants dans le dans ce débat
juste un instant la et on va juste
écouter quelques réactions politiques en
plus qui ont eu lieu au qure colonn cet
après-midi avec Mathilde Panau éc Coti
et Marine Le Pen avec le rejet de cette
loi dès le début de son examen le
pouvoir ferait bien de se rappeler qu'il
existe un parlement dans ce pays et que
le Parlement peut tout à fait voter
contre puisqu'ils sont minoritaires à
l'Assemblée nationale et que
probablement s'il nous avait fait plus
voter sur certains des sujets notamment
sur la question des retraites mais
encore des budgets notamment de la
sécurité sociale à chaque fois ils
auraient eu le même échec je pense que
ce gouvernement comme il ne sait pas où
il va en
réalité croit que la politique c'est du
rodéo c'est il s'agit de rester sur le
cheval même si celui-ci essae de vous
éjecter il s'agit pas d'aller quelque
part il s'agit juste de rester accroché
à la selle donc ils resteront très
certainement accrochés à la selle il
n'en demeure pas moins que le désaveux
qui vient de s'exprimer ce soir est un
aveux extrêmement puissant un désaveux
aussi du en même temps qui est une
véritable escroquerie politique et qui
se révèle sous son vrai visage nous
voulons un texte qui réponde au vrais
défis nous voulons débattre et adopter
dans son intégralité sans ajout sans
modification le texte du Sénat et nous
voulons un engagement très clair pour
une réforme constitutionnelle tel que
nous l'avons présenté jeudi dans
l'hémicycle et malheureusement telle
qu'elle a été brutalement rejetée sans
ménagement par la majorité Olivier rouan
on a entendu Gérald daranin parler
plusieurs fois d'alliance de la carpe et
du lapin qu'est-ce que ça vous fait vous
de voir ces trois responsables
politiques bah se réjouir ensemble de de
ce rejet de de ce refus de débattre je
pense que ce qui a été dit on doit
prendre en compte ce qui a été dit sur
le fait que le dialogue entre législatif
est devenu très difficile avec
l'exécutif du fait d'une accumulation de
mesures utilisées par l'exécutif pour
brider quand même les droits des
parlementaires et notamment C 493 à
répétition l'acte budgétaire c'est quand
même historiquement le pouvoir
parlementaire c'est signifié par sa
capacité à voter un budget et en
discuter et là nous avons eu une
succession de 493 sur le budget donc
forcément ces accumulations bien
permettent ce genre de choses à quelques
voies près est-ce que est-ce ça s'est
déjà produit selon vous historiquement
de voir une telle alliance politique sur
un spectre aussi large que cela ça ça ça
la la la conjonction de des oppositions
a pu se produire sous des républiques
précédentes la dernière motion de rejet
je crois que ça date de 88 à l'Assemblée
nationale au Sénat c'est un peu plus
fréquent mais à l'époque c'était
d'ailleurs il y avait deux types de
motion de rejet bon donc là c'est dû
quand même à cette spécificité du
contexte de 2017 et PU puis à ce ce
dérèglement quand même du fonctionnement
des institutions c'est la fin du en même
temps c'est un désaveux du en même temps
disait Marine Le
Pen c'est dans dans cette façon de faire
vous aviez parlé éventuellement de deux
projets distincts peut-être que ce
serait mieux passer encore on voit bien
qu' qu'on arrive quand même là à des
blocages et euh c'est la fin du en même
temps
euh je vous ai dit tout à l'heure la fin
du en même temps ce sera lorsque ou bien
on aura une nouvelle élection qui remet
en place un clivage droite gauche ou
bien on aura un centre qui est consolidé
mais tant qu'on restera dans une
majorité très composite et qui peut se
fragiliser sur des questions clvantes et
bien non ça sera ça sera toujours un peu
en même temps et un peu toujours cette
idée de temps en temps avec la gauche de
temps en temps avec la droite parce que
somme toute quand même depuis 2 ans ça
fonctionne comme ça alors c'est vrai que
ça empêche de voter des textes lourds
hein on est il y a eu des lois sur
l'énergie nucléaire sur le climat ici ou
là il y a eu mais sur les textes lourds
les retraites 493 le budget 493 donc
c'est ces problématiqu sur un
fonctionnement délibératif des
institutions alors on va se replonger
plus en détail sur l'histoire de ce
projet de loi qui est loin d'avoir été
un long fleuve tranquille rien n'a été
simple dès la présentation de ce texte
en conseil des ministres c'était le 1er
février dernier pour ce texte qui est
très étroitement associé à un homme un
ministre le ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald dararmanin Stéphanie des piierre
nous rafraîchit la mémoire le
gouvernement avait choisi de commencer
les débats au Sénat pour verrouiller les
discussions avec la droite la première
étape est franchie sans trop de
difficultés pour géralde Darmanin les
sénateurs durcissent le texte mais ils
le votent le 14 novembre quand la loi
arrive en commission à l'Assemblée
géralde d'armanin a gagné une première
bataille mais il sait qu'il marche sur
un fil il doit convaincre les députés
les républicains encore plus réticents
que leurs collègues sénateurs de voter
le texte lo imig
Perre le soutien de l' GAE de sa propre
majorité début décembre la loi est
largement modifiée par Renaissance et
ses alliés et adopté en commission mais
mercredi les écologistes et les
républicains déposent chacun une motion
de rejet le camp présidentielle comprend
alors que toutes les oppositions peuvent
s'allier pour rejeter la loi immigration
avant même que le débat ne commence un
peu avant 18h cet après-midi les
républicains et le rassemblement
national votent avec la gauche la motion
de rejet est adoptée pour 270 contre
265 c'est un immense désaveux pour
géralde dararmanin pour la première fois
depuis la réélection d'Emmanuel Macron
la coalition de toutes les oppositions a
mise en échec le gouvernement sur un
texte majeur alors dans la soirée on a
appris donc que Géral daranin avait été
reçu à l'Élysée par Emmanuel Macron
qu'il avait proposé au Président de la
République sa démission que celui-ci l'a
refusé je me tourne vers vous trois
représentants des oppositions
auriez-vous souhaité qu'Emmanuel Macron
accepte la démission de Gérald
dararmanin à la suite de ce revers non
alors pour ce qui nous concerne nous
n'avons pas crié comme certains de nos
collègues d'armanin d'émission parce que
nous ce que nous voulons ce que nous
avons voulu signifier par ce vote c'est
un coup de semonce politique c'est dire
au gouvernement en matière d'immigration
vous ne pouvez pas faire le en même
temps habituel un peu de mesure d'un
côté de gauche un peu de mesure de
droite la faute originelle en réalité
est celle de géralde Darmanin en effet
alors parce que parce que comme une
faute doiton assumer les les
responsabilités bah il a oui il a pris
ses responsabilités puisqu'il a présenté
sa démission que le Président de la
République a a refusé appelant à donner
une suite moi j'espère qu'il y aura une
suite le débat parlementaire doit se
poursuivre mais le la faute originelle
du ministre de l'intérieur est d'avoir
pour faire voter positivement le Sénat
accepter toutes les mesures de droite et
les avoir toutes refusé en commission à
l'Assemblée nationale faisant ainsi
organisant des positions
irréconciliables qui croire est-ce qu'il
faut croire le ministre de l'intérieur
du Sénat ou le ministre de l'Intérieur à
l'Assemblée nationale donc nous nous
avons dit très clairement la version de
la commission des lois c'est pas
possible mais nous souhaitons mais nous
souhaitons la poursuite évidemment du
processus parlementaire on va en parler
dans un instant mais j'aimerais juste
finir un petit peu ce tour de table
avoir votre avis à vous Arthur de la
porte sur le sort de Gérald daranin j'ai
bien aimé cette expression de
photoriginelle il y a pas eu qu'une
faute originelle il y a eu aussi tout ce
qui s'est passé après cette espèce de de
corruption à la fois morale parce que
finalement Gérald Darmanin a précipité
la macronie et notamment cette espèce de
jambe gauche en carton mais voilà en se
en se courant dans dans les dans les
jupons de de LR pour reprendre une
expression toujours un petit peu
spéciale mais c'est vrai que moi j'avais
l'impression que pendant toute de la
commission ils étaient en train
d'essayer de montrer que il reprenaient
les avancées du Sénat il reprenaient les
avancées du Sénat c'est-à-dire en fait
les reculs sur les droits fondamentaux
les reculs sur les principes qui sont
ceux de la République et donc finalement
une corruption morale mais il y avait
aussi un autre problème de Gérald Darman
c'est qu'il a cherché à draguer
individuellement les parlementaires en
les recevant à déjeuner en essayant de
les acheter comme ça en leur promettant
des choses dans leur circonscription et
malheureusement même ça ça n'a pas à
marcher et c'est peut-être une bonne
chose finalement parce que c'est une dou
erreur une erreur stratégique une erreur
sur la forme une erreur sur le fond
voyez il s'est un peu cramé Gérald
d'Anin donc pour moi il aurait dû
évidemment non seulement remettre sa
démission mais le président de la
République aurait dû l'accepter en
quelques mots très vite jeis désolé
Johan Gillet votre avis sur le sort
politique de Gérald armanin je pense que
Gérald armanin aurait dû démissionner
bien avant bien avant après tous les
drames qui ont touché notre pays tous
les les actes terroristes toutes les
agressions tous ces assassinats dont il
pent une resp responsabilité parce qu'il
n'a pas mis en œuvre un certain nombre
de mesures mais pour voir plus loin le
problème aujourd'hui c'est que les
Français ont une vision très claire de
la politique migratoire qu'ils veulent
ils sont 81 % à demander le retour du
délit de séjour irrégulier ils sont 68 %
à approuver la mesure proposée par
Marine Le Pen de transformer l'ame en en
Amu pardon ils sont également très
nombreux à vouloir et à combattre la
régularisation des des clandestins
travailleurs et ça c'est une ligne rouge
que nous ne voulons pas franchir parce
qu'il faut le rappeler la régularisation
des travailleurs clandestins en réalité
elle a été approuvée par tout le monde
sauf par nous pourquoi je dis tout le
monde
par à sa porte mais moi le sondage que
j'ai vu sur la régularisation des
travailleurs sans pa dans les secteur
enension il y a une majorité
favorable avait voté pour l'article 3 en
commission des Lois du Sénat et ensuite
on proposait l'article 4 bis qui n'est
ni plus ni moins que l'article 3
revisité au Sénat donc la réalité c'est
quoi quand madame jeunevard dit que
leslr veulent le texte à la sortie du
Sénat la réalité c'est que leslr du coup
veulent la régularisation des
travailleurs alors attendez parce que
vous parlez de l'avenir de ce texte et
justement c'est ce qui nous intéresse on
a envie de se projeter dans l'avenir sur
ce texte et on va en parler avec vous
Elsa mandingava quelles sont les options
dont dispose le gouvernement pour ce
texte et bien écoutez vous l'avez dit le
ministre de l'intérieur était sur tfin
il y a quelques minutes il a confirmé
qu'il avait présenté sa démission une
démission refusée par le président de la
République alors il faut maintenant
s'intéresser à la suite ce soir le
ministre a rendez-vous avec la première
ministre ellisabeth borne ainsi que les
présidents des groupes parlementaires de
la majorité il y a trois options retirer
le texte continuer la navette avec un
retour du texte au Sénat ou bien la
convocation d'une CMP une commission
mixte paritaire cette réunion entre SEP
députés se sénateurs chargé de trouver
un compromis là on repartirait du texte
du Sénat et la droite il y a beaucoup de
poids donc donc on irait vers plus un un
durcissement du texte la décision donc
devrait être prise ce soir ou demain
dans la majorité on entend des voix
divergentes certains veulent une CMP
rapide avant la fin là avant la fin de
l'année avant les vacances de Noël
d'autres considèrent qu'il faut prendre
le temps de digérer digérer la claque
que s'est pris le gouvernement donc vous
le voyez ce soir il y aura des
discussions justement sur les différents
scénarios possibles en tout cas le
retrait du texte on y'y croit pas
tellement dans la majorité merci
beaucoup Elsa Mondin Gava qui évoquait à
l'instant une majorité qui se divise un
peu sur les choix stratégiques à faire
sur l'avenir de ce texte et bien on va
poser la question tout simplement à
Frédéric Valtou du groupe horizon qui
est à à vos côté Clément perouot bonsoir
Frédéric Valtou bonsoir ela disait
faut-il prendre le temps de digérer
cette défaite ou au contraire convoquer
très vite une commission mixte paritaire
quelle est votre opinion à vous bah s'il
doit y avoir une digestion elle doit
être rapide et et la nuit fera son
office je pense que dès demain il faut
clarifier la situation et et et dire
effectivement ce que le gouvernement ce
que la majorité présidentielle souhaite
et et à titre personnel et et et au nom
du groupe horizon nous on souhaite la
poursuite du du débat parlementaire
c'est-à-dire le texte ne tombe pas parce
que cette motion de rejet a été votée
euh c'est un échec évidemment il faut le
appeler un chat un chat mais néanmoins
le parcours parlementaire continue euh
idéalement il faudrait euh pourquoi pas
convoquer une CMP euh et permettre
effectivement de continuer à discuter
avec la majorité sénatoriale puisque la
majorité sénatoriale au moins c'est une
majorité constructive elle a souhaité et
elle a montré qu'elle était capable de
discuter avec le gouvernement euh et
donc il faut continuer effectivement
pour que le le texte chemine faut pas
surtout pas s'arrêter là remonter très
vite à cheval finalement c'est ce que
vous préconisez si le texte revient à
l'Assemblée dans une version beaucoup
plus proche de celle du Sénat vous
députés horizon est-ce que vous le
voterez je vais pas faire des avec des
silles parce que on verra on verra ce
que donne la discussion avec la majorité
présidentielle pourquoi il faut pas
s'arrêter dès ce soir pourquoi il faut
pas baisser les bras on a assisté à à
une petite séquence de peties politiques
politiciennees puisque ce qui a été
adopté c'est une motion de renvoie une
motion de procédure pour ne pas rentrer
dans le dans la discussion voter par des
gens qui ne pensent pas du tout la même
chose du texte mais ils pensent même
l'exact contraire entre le RN et
l'anupes au milieu LR ne sait plus ce
qu'il pense et donc ils sont suivistes
euh il faut rappeler que en commission
tous ces gens-là ont discuté et pendant
euh une semaine avec des soirées qui on
terminé très tard et la dernier soir à
3h du matin euh la discussion a eu lieu
entre les uns et les autres et pourtant
ils se sont tous entendus pour sur une
motion qui veut dire simplement une
chose on rejette le texte parce qu'on ne
veut pas le discuter on ne veut pas
rentrer du dans le fond du débat voyez
donc c'est totalement inepte et je
parlais de LR il faut dire et rappeler
qu'en commission LR ils étaient quatre
en commission deux ont voté pour le
texte deux ont voté contre donc on voit
bien que même chez LR la discussion elle
était pas si claire que ça c c'est une
motion politicienne il faut pas
s'arrêter à ça il faut continuer le
parcours parlementaire pour moi c'est
l'essentiel merci à vous merci Merci à
VOUS Clément per je me tourne vers vous
Ludovic mendz pour avoir votre point de
vue après celui de Frédéric Valtou vous
êtes plutôt favorable à une CMP
commission mixte paritaire on se met
d'accord entre députés et sénateurs sans
débat public ou un retour du texte au
Sénat avec une navette et donc la
possibilité éventuel d'un débat à
l'Assemblée c'est pas nous qui avons
refuser le débat public donc à partir de
là on a des possibilités de faire
certaines choses pourquoi ne pas ne pas
continuer si les sénateurs sont prêts à
travaill avec nous faisons-le je veux
dire nous on était prêt à travailler on
narrête pas de dire depuis le départ
qu'on veut débattre et comprendre s'il
faut on était prêt à prendre tout le
temps qu'on voulait et volontairement
Géral har av dire on était prêt aller
jusqu'au mois d'avril s'il le fallait
l'idée c'est que certains refusent parce
qu'ils veulent pas entendre certaines
choses qu'ils refuse l'arrêter de notre
pays d'autres ne savent pas où ils
habitent donc ils ont essayé de nous
faire du mal mais moi il y a une chose
que je ne comprends pas c'est pourquoi
ne pas avoir accepté de débattre pendant
15 jours et au pire des cas un véritable
camouflé serit é de voter contre ce
texte de loi et de démontrer qu'ils
étaient vraiment contre après vraiment
15 jours de débat où chacun a pu
s'exprimer que les députés du RN se lèv
chacun son tour comme un étandard euh un
un un député sandwich au nom de Marine
Le Pen en permanence comme ils le font
que les LR puisse nous expliquer là où
on est pas bon là où on est bon ou pas
que les les les hommes du Parti
socialiste nous explique que ils ne
peuvent survivre qu'avec la France
insoumise parce que en l'état ils sont
en train de disparaître la réalité c'est
ça c'est que certains jouent leur vatou
pour continuer à exister parce qu'il y a
2027 il y a les européennes il y a
toutes ces rité là donc vous tous a été
pollués par des enjeux on est tous pris
on est tous pollués parce que le
problème de la politique en France et je
crois que le le le général de Gaul avait
raison c'est les partis le problème
c'est les partis politiques si on ne
sort pas du dogme politique et qu'on
accepte pas d'avoir des débats parfois
durs très dur d'accepter de souffrir de
la haine portée par le rassemblement
national ou alors de la haine portée par
la France insoumise alors on on a rien à
faire à l'Assemblée nationale
démissionner de votre poste on est là
pour représenter les Français les
Français nous ont nous ont élu de cette
façon là il faut l'accepter vous l'avez
vu quand même les députés de la macronie
jamais ne se remettent en question et là
vous êtes en train d'accuser au début de
l'émission monsieur mendz a a reconnu
une part de responsabilité de la
majorité dans cet éche a voté pour cette
motion de rejet pour des raisons très
différentes avec mon collègue d'extrême
gauche évidemment partir de la porte
d'extrême
gaucheme parti de Laup donc je considère
d'extrême gauche mais en tout cas on a
voté pour des raisons très différentes
ça c'est très clair mais la macronie
jamais ne se remet en question la vérité
c'est que votre texte tel qu'il était là
ne convenait à personne ne
pas représentant du
peuple représente le peuple et donc ici
ouié qui soit plus ferme représente récl
pardon encore une fois la suppression du
droit du sol il demande à ce que l'on
coupe VO réagir C éch juste une remarque
relative à ce qui se passe si le
cheminement se poursuit du texte bon euh
c'est une stratégie payante pour LR euh
parce que c'est ce qu'il voulait oui
dans la mesure où répété plusieurs fois
sur la version du sén du LR aussi
puisqu'ils viennent de Rogier
manifestement assez durement une
éventuelle présidentialité de Gérald
daranin bon il reste du temps mais enfin
ils ont se sont là vengés comme ils font
souvent vis-à-vis d'un de leurs anciens
qui les quitent hein il y a un peu cette
dimension dans dans ce qui se passe
quand même Pr il y a une inimité
personnelle
apparemment disaient on veut la mort de
Gérald arm on veut la peau de géralis
une troisième remarque quand même
c'est moi je pense je je laisse ça à la
réflexion que c'est la faiblesse des
partis politiques qui a un problème
c'est pas le fait qu'ils soit trop fort
c'est qu'ils sont devenus très faibles
et c'est la raison pour laquelle ils
sont extrêmement liquides du fait de
leur division Arthur de la porte vous
voulez juste reondir sur ça parce que je
suis totalement d'accord avec cette
analyse sur le fait que le problème
c'est la faiblesse des partis politiques
pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui le
spectacle que nous offre la majorité
présidentielle c'est un spectacle de
désidéologisation absolue en fait on est
prêt à tout mélanger à tout mixer au nom
d'une réalité vous avez dit tout à
l'heure vous refusez de voir la réalité
mais laquelle monsieur Mendes laquelle
celle des gens que on côtoie aujourd'hui
au quotidien dont je parlais tout à
l'heure celle ceux qui sont sousocutf ou
celles et ceux qui sont des demandeurs
d'asile et qui aujourd'hui sont à la rue
c'est ça la réalité en fait c'est la
France qui ne remplit pas sa mission moi
je suis allé à la frontière
franco-italienne je suis allé dans le
poste de police aux frontières et j'ai
vu une réalité elle est indigne de la
France vous avez dans 30 m²r dans 30 m²r
vous avez parfois 40 femmes enfants
mineurs qui passent la nuit sans
sanitaire ça c'est la réalité sans
douche oui sans médecin sans pouvoir
même déposer l'asile alors qu'ils
viennent de payer en guerre ça c'est la
réalité de la France et ça jamais je ne
l'ai entend débat pourquoi parce que on
est sur un espèce de débat estce que
vous ne risquez pas d'être confronté
juste à un texte plus plus dur dans sa
version remé par le Sénat ça c'est ça
c'est une
espèce pas du tout je vais revenir sur
cette espèce de d'élément de langage que
j'entends depuis le début à cause de ça
le texte va être durci mais pas du tout
ça ne changera absolument rien puisque à
la fin si le texte continue son parcours
ce que je ne souhaite pas c'est une
commission mixte paritaire dont la
composition est figée depuis le départ
la majorité présidentielle c'est-à-dire
la minorité l'Assemblée nationale aura
ses représentants les républicains
auront leurs représentants et c'est eux
à la fin qui feront un pour fabriquer un
texte donc peu importe finalement que ce
soit sur la base du texte de l'Assemblée
ou du Sénat ça ne change strictement
rien pour avoir fait un certain nombre
de CMP d'ailleurs on prend souvent la
base du Sénat qui est la base de
discussion pour trouver des compromis
mais moi je n'ai pas envie de faire un
compromis avec les républicains si c'est
le choix de la majorité il faudra qu'il
l'assume nous on leur propose une autre
voie c'est celle du retrait du texte
c'est
bon le retrait n'aura pas lieu les
différents groupes en tout cas de la
majorité ont lancé un appel contre un
retrait de ce texte Annie je vous voulez
réagir aussi oui moi je je souhaite que
le texte poursuive son examen je pense
que c'est indispensable parce que la
réalité que connaî notre pays
aujourd'hui le mérite le demande les
Français d'ailleurs ne s'y trompent pas
de toutes les formations politiques de
toutes les sensibilités politique ils
disent entre 700 et 900000 personnes en
séjour irrégulier en France c'est pas
possible de continuer comme ça la
régularisation dans les métiers en
tension alors qu'il y a 6 millions de
demandeurs d'emploi dont 3
oupéang situation régulère qui sont au
chômage vous évoquez l'inhumanité de
certaines situations je la partage je
partage votre révolte mais chaque fois
que vous donner des signaux en faveur
d'une immigration incontrôlée vous
nourrissz
en c'est ré c'est la réalité des
ches qu' unee absence de solution crée
écoutez les élus locaux
écout écoutez les élus locaux qui vous
parlent de l'impossibilité à gérer les
jeunes mineurs non accompagnés qui sont
la proie des passeurs qui sont la proie
des marchands de sommeil et et et ou ou
ceux qui périssent en mer s'il n'y a pas
des règles claires et fermes et bien
vous êtes condamnés à vous indigné comme
vous venez de le faire et moi aussi je
suis je suis indigné par les conditions
dans lesqu vivent certains êtres humains
vous croyez qu'on est insensible à ces
situationperchez depuis le début à
instrumentaliser l'étranger comme un
criminel c'est ce que vous faites dans
absolument pas dans les demandeurs
d'asile monsieur de la porte et vous le
savez très bien il y a 70 % de faux
demandeur d'asile et ils resteront en
France situation
irrgul 96 % donc cette
situation on a compris en tout cas qu'il
y a matière à débat sur ce sujet de
l'immigration ça c'est clair juste il y
a juste un
pointmission Ronner il faut redonner la
parole au peuple français et il faut un
référendum sur le thème de l'immigration
et là on aura un texte qui sera accepté
par les Français et qui aura toute
légitimité il a juste avant de conclure
il nous reste très peu de temps il y a
un mot qui a pas été prononcé sur les
leçons à tiré de cet échec dissolution
ou pas de l'assemblé personne n'en veut
de cette dissolution finalement ça ne le
mérite pas ce qui s'est produit
aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée ce n'est pas
une des leçons politiques à tirer il n'y
a pas de majorité on demande aux
Français de revoter de retourner aux
urnes pour faire en sorte qu'une
majorité se dégage dans cette assemblée
on n'est pas devant un échec on n'est
pas obligé d'abdiquer et d'abandonner
veux dire quand la France perd en coup
tout mond n pas dit que c'était la faute
de son2000 mêlé alors que tout le monde
le voyait comme il est le meilleur Jeur
du monde l'arrêté elle est là c'est
c'est pas parce qu' chaque fois on a un
échec on est dans l'obligation de
s'échapper et de vouloir enterrer sur le
tapis non on peut revenir débattre il y
a d'autres textes de loi il y a d'autres
obligations il faut qu'on le prenne en
considération merci beaucoup à tous les
quatre et à tous les cinq avec vous
Olivier Roucan même si vous n'êtes pas
député évidemment merci beaucoup d'être
venu débattre sur ce sur ce plateau euh
l'antenne d' LCP reprend son cours
normal à partir de demain avec
savourgarde et myiam ankawawa passe une
bonne soirée sur notre antenne à
bientôt